[Musique]
dessiner et concevoir l'avion du futur
exige des années de préparation
découverte a appris que bombardier
planchait sur des technologies
futuristes un accès exclusif
bon parti prépare l'avenir à l'insu des
autres constructeurs l'entreprise
travaille sur un projet secret établir
les bases de ce que deviendra l'avion du
futur
avec ce projet on a créé pas un nouveau
programme d'avions essentiellement ce
qu'on crise est une plateforme de
recherche développement sur laquelle on
va migrer et intégrer toutes sortes de
nouvelles technologiques sont
prometteuses
derrière cette porte un bunker seule une
dizaine d'ingénieurs y ont accès c'est
là que bombardier ébauche le futur
découverte appuyant tri un accès
exclusif
en aéronautique
un cycle de recherche et de
développement s'échelonne sur une
vingtaine d'années a eu besoin de cinq à
dix ans pour amener une technologie au
bon niveau de maturité et on a besoin
d'un autre cinq à dix ans pour
développer un programme d'avions il
mettre en service
l'objectif ultime produire des jets
d'affaires plus vers des avions qui
consomment moins carburant
l'objectif 9 0c vraiment de réduire au
maximum les émissions de carbone des
produits combatif on investit 90 % de
nos ressources de recherche et
développement pour atteindre cet
objectif
la grande majorité des améliorations
décarbonisation vont venir de la
motorisation et de la performance de
lèvres la combinaison des deux va
représenter 80% des de la réduction des
émissions
premier défi d'augmenter la portance de
l'appareil tout en réduisant la friction
de l'air ce qu'on appelle la traînée on
y va donc d'un changement radical on
fusionne les ailes au fuselage
c'est la naissance de l'est le fuselage
intégrer les avions qui volent
présentement dans le ciel ce sont deux
configurations conventionnel maintenant
les le fuselage intégrer une
configuration non conventionnelles donc
les avions qu'on connaît sont
généralement fuselage très cylindrique
qu on vient rajouter une aile de chaque
côté pour générer la porte est
maintenant avec une configuration elle
fuselage intégrer on ne puisse cette
discontinuité entre les deux composants
donc les surfaces sont beaucoup plus dos
à cette connexion le
réduire la turbulence c'est l'autre défi
c'est en améliorant l'ale que bombardier
compte y arriver
si on pense au global 7500 par exemple
c'est une aile de quatrième génération
qui est tout à fait extraordinaire c'est
une aile qui est très performante à très
haute vitesse est aussi performante à
basse vitesse maintenant on travaille à
une aile de cinquième génération
donc on est des outils des algorithmes
d'optimisation qui nous permette d'aller
chercher les meilleures performances
aérodynamiques possible en un court laps
de temps dont on est capable de tester
tout plein de surfaces différentes
et puis d'aller chercher quels sont les
meilleurs
le dernier défi est numérique en ce
moment logiciel peut simuler une
manoeuvre en vol ou le comportement de
l'ale pendant cette manoeuvre mais on ne
peut simuler les deux à la fois on veut
maintenant créer un jumeau numérique une
représentation virtuelle de l'appareil
ou 100% des interactions 100% des
systèmes seront simulés
l'utilisation du superordinateur est
absolument critique pour nos calculs
numérique en fait parce qu'on a des
millions de points même des centaines de
millions de points dans certains cas qui
doivent être résoudre sur des équations
différentielles très complexe ça nous
permet de faire des prédictions
aérodynamique qui sont ensuite validées
par des tests en soufflerie ou même des
tests en vol soit avec des véhicules à
pleine grandeur soit avec des véhicules
réduits
aussi puissant soit-il il y a des
limites à ce qu'un ordinateur peut faire
il faut mener des essais en vol voici le
drone de bombardier on dévoile au public
pour la première fois
le chef
puisque le design du drone est nouveau
nous n'avons encore récolté aucune
donnée sur l'appareil à son historique
ce sont donc les essais en vol qui vont
nous permettre de documenter son
comportement c'est une façon moins
traditionnel de collecter des données en
fait c'est très différent des essais en
soufflerie ou encore des essais en vol
fait avec un avion grandeur nature c'est
vol à petite échelle c'est très nouveau
pour nous
à l'abri des regards dans un lieu qu'on
ne peut dévoiler bombardier amorce une
série d'essais
ya beaucoup d'incertitude on connait
bien une configuration conventionnel
mais une configuration non
conventionnelles comme ça la stabilité
le contrôle d'un modèle comme ça c'est
différent et c'est un truc qu'on essaie
d'étudier avec les drones quelles sont
les lois de contrôle qu'on a besoin pour
être capable de vraiment bien contrôlée
un appareil comme ça
le drone est construit à petite échelle
sa structure représente 7% de celle d'un
jet d'affaires
il pèse 23 kg pour une envergure de 2 m
on essaie de mieux comprendre la
configuration non conventionnelles dont
on commence à petite échelle et pied
éventuellement on va aller à des
échelles plus importante bardée de
capteurs le drone enregistre 2000
paramètres lesquels sont transmis en
direct la salle de télémétrie à montréal
enregistrons beaucoup de données sur le
comportement de l'avion des données sur
le mouvement sur la vitesse et sur les
angles par exemple on enregistre tout ce
qui peut nous être utile et on le fait
aussi souvent que possible
ces capteurs peuvent enregistrer jusqu'à
100 données par seconde et au final ce
sont toutes ces données qui nous
permettent de faire le calcul mais quand
tu triches troupe
seconde a complété une soixantaine de
sorties pour environ 200 heures de vol
le prochain drone sera deux fois plus
gros i les essais en vol s'amorceront
dans l'ouest canadien d'ici l'été
j'ai mon parti mayer dans l'industrie on
rêve d'un jet d'affaires 100 %
électrique
défi principal c'est vraiment la densité
énergétique des batteries les batteries
sont beaucoup trop lourde pour
l'utilisation en aviation donc on va
devoir travailler pour une technologie
ou est ce que la performance des
batteries sera aux cinq fois plus grande
que ce qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui
sur le marché le développement des
batteries électriques n'étant pas un
domaine de recherche chez bombardier
constructeurs demeure tributaire de la
recherche internationale
mais chaque avancée chaque nouveauté
permettra de diminuer le poids de
l'avion et par le fait même la
consommation d'énergie prenons comme
exemple
l'électrification du système de
dégivrage dès ailes
donc le système de dégivrage et un
système très complexe avec de la tue au
triple double avec des systèmes de profs
de détection et de protection qui sont
très complexes à la faune que c'est très
lourd et d'un point de vue installation
dans la viande production east c'est
très complexe on aura pas demain un
avion 100 % électrique donc on va devoir
intégrer des technologies graduellement
système par système pour graduellement
transformer l'avion électrique
imaginer le futur
concevoir l'avion du futur une marche
vers l'inconnu
quand qu'on innove encore avec des
nouvelles configurations il faut en
quelque sorte réapprendre donc il faut
explorer to play de différentes avenues
certaines avenues vont se montrer plus
prometteuse que d'autres donc on explore